gary unfriended me on facebook
i know i say i don't give a [ __ ] but i
gotta admit i was like
that [ __ ] [ __ ] but it's so like why
it's moronic it is it's so show related
not life related it's just stupid
like i don't but when do i ever goof
what did i say that was so terrible
i told gary that it was fun to see him
on facebook at the mets game
oh my god did you [ __ ] hate that as
much as i did
[ __ ] gary with like you know how
excited he is with the met game
this is a dream come true me and my son
at the milk game it's like [ __ ] you
i just said i thought it was funny
listen i'm going to the world series
again with jackson's wedding i'm going
to put up more pictures
i don't want to hear more [ __ ] but you
don't unfriend your boss it's stupid
do you really care yeah i think i do
i want to tell you why you're a man my
facebook is not a public facebook it's
just
okay can i tell you something yeah you
want to hear why you're a [ __ ]
i don't know what you did wrong but yes
i went on my facebook
i'm completely on gary's page i'm not
unfriended
i can see everything on there i it said
unfriend maybe i hit the wrong button
you hit the wrong button so if you're
going on for me do it the [ __ ] right
because you're still friends then he
wouldn't even be
meeting the mets if it wasn't for me he
met the [ __ ] mets at kimmel who
should get the picture first
i mean i mean holy moly
jackson is going to be able to do
anything you want
jackson's going to the met game because
of me jackson
went to school because of me jackson was
born because of you
jackson's more my son because if i if it
weren't for howard i wouldn't
marry and not maybe there's no jack kind
of yeah i think
yeah and then you can unfriend me after
everything i mean
why would you even you know gary thought
it was no big deal
he was telling people around the office
some people had such a look of shock on
their face from unfriending me
somebody i got to tell you something
[ __ ] you and you know what i am
unfriending you as well
we won't miss each other on facebook now
but what you are going to miss is that
now that we're not friends anymore don't
come to my house okay
all right strictly business okay okay
pal but why wouldn't he unfriend me
because he knows i'll robin's worse than
me i realized yesterday i have to
unfriend howard
uh robin how about that jason jason's
got to be big unfriended
it's just a dumb business thing for you
to do it's
it's not business if you know me i'm a
kook it could [ __ ] stick in my crawl
why would you do that how about thanks
to the world's greatest wolf
you know what i mean there are people i
hate i don't unfriend
it's crazy it's just crazy you're not
thinking clearly yes sir
jesus if i was you i'd double friend me
but
what you by the way i'm not only
friending howard
i just want everyone on facebook to know
he's my best friend
over all of you mary must want a divorce
because he's so [ __ ] dumb my wife
left me why is that
because i'm so stupid i've locked my
ball on facebook
he doesn't unfriend the dentist who did
those [ __ ] horrible caps
but me he unfriends the dentist who did
that to him he's best friends
he was nice to that guy i know how about
i unemploy him